russia says it has begun to withdraw
troops from the crimea territory that
moscow annexed from ukraine in 2014. the
russian defense ministry says military
drills in the region are over and that
tanks and soldiers are returning to
their bases yesterday the kremlin
announced it was pulling back some
forces from its border with ukraine
western allies have welcomed the
statement but say they need to see
evidence that the withdrawal is
happening
meanwhile ukraine celebrating a day of
unity president vladimir zelinsky has
declared a day of celebration citizens
are being asked to fly the flag from
buildings and to sing the national
anthem some u.s officials have
previously warned that wednesday would
see russia start an invasion of ukraine
the russian defense minister reported
today
that some military units are leaving
their positions near ukraine
that would be good
but we have not yet verified that we
have not yet verified the russian
military units are returning to their
home bases
indeed our analysts indicate that they
remain very much in a threatening
position
and the fact remains right now russia
has more than 150 000 troops encircling
ukraine and belarus and along ukraine's
border
an invasion remains distinctly possible
well that warning from president biden
follows the german chancellor's talks
with president putin yesterday and with
ukraine's president in kiev the day
before
speaking in moscow olaf schultz repeated
calls for an urgent de-escalation
it was his most important trip abroad to
date olaf schultz arrived in moscow to
carry out what he sees as one of his key
tasks building bridges with russia and
the bridge is badly needed as the world
remains on high alert over a possible
russian invasion of ukraine
while schultz made his way to the
kremlin
the russian parliament sent a strong
signal to the west
members of the duma asked their
president to recognize two breakaway
regions in eastern ukraine as
independent
a move that could kill off what remains
of the minsk peace process
difficult preconditions for schultz's
crisis talks with vladimir putin
the leaders looked for ways to close the
gap between russia and the west
speaking afterwards to the media both
said they were determined to defuse
tensions
i want to say one thing for my
generation war in europe has become
unthinkable and we must ensure it stays
that way
as heads of state and government it's
our damn responsibility and our job to
prevent a military escalation in
europe do we want war or not of course
not
that is why we have made proposals to
start the negotiation process
this should lead to an agreement of
providing equal security for everybody
including our country
so more talks are needed for a
diplomatic breakthrough and yet there
are small signs the threat may be
subsiding
over the course of the day russia said
it was withdrawing some of its more than
a hundred thousand troops along the
border with ukraine
if those claims turn out to be true it
would be the first sign of the
escalation in weeks
well let's get more from dwc chief
political editor michaela kouffner who
was uh traveling with chancellor schultz
yesterday on his trip to moscow welcome
mikhaila russia says it's withdrawing
some troops from ukraine's border is it
too early to breathe a sigh of relief
no it isn't you can have a sigh of
relief certainly that immediate military
threat seems to be off the cards for now
while moscow vladimir putin also
speaking to olaf shaw is the german
chancellor there
was stressing that he would maintain
his interests and that means keeping up
the pressure so
it seems to be that those intelligence
reports
may or may not have been part of a
strategy as well
to basically convey the message that yes
the threat was immediate that action was
needed and that there needed to be
some kind of reaction on the russian
side as well
to engage in dialogue to prevent those
sanctions because those are ready they
can kick in at any time and that is a
message that seems to really have
arrived in moscow as well okay now the
uh the german chancellor was uh in
moscow yesterday and i know you were
there on that trip so we'll take a look
at the report from yesterday and then
come back to you
or not as the case may be all right so
that's not ready but we are so michaela
um did the uh did the chancellor come
back with anything yesterday
well he certainly come back with some
breathing space for diplomacy and he
basically called on all leaders western
leaders and vladimir putin that is their
duty to ensure that there is not another
war in europe i got the chance to ask
vladimir putin about that whether it
would be war peace and he was adamant
that russia also has no interest in a
real war and we saw both leaders having
very deep engaged talks that's what i
heard afterwards but also even on
arrival there was an air of kind of cold
war when um olaf schwartz the german
chancellor like emmanuel macron had
refused to take a russian pcr test he
actually took one on board the plane so
very mixed messages of not really
trusting each other but at the same time
very concrete talks with very in
concrete
results so far
okay and this was uh this was mr
schultz's first meeting with president
uh putin who has known um his
predecessor for 16 years of
international meetings so how did the
novice do against the old hand
well they had a certainly a very engaged
exchange uh in the press conference um
also with all of shorts cracking a joke
almost about um he doesn't know how long
vladimir putin wants to remain in office
but he personally certainly won't stay
forever that's a hint at the democratic
deficits that keep him in office
eternally it seems and what we
understand from what we heard afterwards
is that there were very detailed talks
that actually there was a friendliness
to those talks as well
so that kind of can see us be a bit more
hopeful that diplomacy might get a
chance and also highlights that division
of roles that there clearly was in the
west with the u.s president biden doing
the tough talking and german chancellor
olaf schweitz also by not mentioning
the north stream pipeline directly not
saying directly that that would not go
ahead if russia invades ukraine again
and that they that may have paid off
that one is being a bit softer and uh
successful at engaging vladimir putin
into yet more dialogue okay thank you
for that michaela kufner our dwc chief
political editor
well president biden's warning regarding
russian claims to have withdrawn its
troops follows withdraw on some of its
troops follows chancellor schultz's
meeting
with uh president putin yesterday and
speaking in moscow olaf schultz repeated
calls for an urgent de-escalation
it was his most important trip abroad to
date olaf schultz arrived in moscow to
carry out what he sees as one of his key
tasks building bridges with russia and
the bridge is badly needed as the world
remains on high alert over a possible
russian invasion of ukraine
while schultz made his way to the
kremlin
the russian parliament sent a strong
signal to the west
members of the duma ask their president
to recognize two breakaway regions in
eastern ukraine as independent
a move that could kill off what remains
of the minsk peace process
difficult preconditions for schultz's
crisis talks with vladimir putin
the leaders looked for ways to close the
gap between russia and the west
speaking afterwards to the media both
said they were determined to defuse
tensions
i want to say one thing for my
generation war in europe has become
unthinkable and we must ensure it stays
that way
as heads of state and government it's
our damn responsibility and our job to
prevent a military escalation in europe
do we want war or not of course not
that is why we have made proposals to
start the negotiation process
this should lead to an agreement of
providing equal security for everybody
including our country
so more talks are needed for a
diplomatic breakthrough and yet there
are small signs the threat may be
subsiding
over the course of the day russia said
it was withdrawing some of its more than
a hundred thousand troops along the
border with ukraine
if those claims turn out to be true it
would be the first sign of the
escalation in
weeks uh michaela kufner is still with
us welcome back um you were able to put
the first question uh to president putin
at yesterday's press conference uh tell
us about how that that went
yes well that was quite an interesting
moment because deutsche weller actually
is only able to report um from moscow at
the moment because i was there as part
of that group traveling with the german
chancellor and i asked um vladimir putin
whether despite all those close ties
between russia and its european partners
actually they're certainly economic
partners cultural partners there would
now be war and that's where we saw the
answer there that he said well of course
we don't want any war but um we also
heard the definition of wanting equal
stability uh balance stability in europe
now clearly that's something that nato
or the european union felt
that was there already and vladimir
putin sent a clear message that he will
not back down unless there is a
redefinition of what that means
he put a list of demands which also
would mean that nato does not enlarge
does not include ukraine nato won't
accept that it sent a written reply and
that is seen as something as at least a
basis a starting point to now engage in
more talks okay thank you for that
michaela michaela kufner
meanwhile ukraine is celebrating a day
of unity president vladimir zelinski has
declared a day of celebration citizens
are being asked to fly the flag from
buildings and sing the national anthem
some u.s officials had previously warned
that wednesday would see russia start an
invasion of the country
[Music]
well dw correspondent nick connolly is
in ukraine's northern city of kharkiv
near the russian border uh welcome nick
so as i said today's the day that
president biden said uh to expect a
russian attack on ukraine but in fact
russian troops are said to be
withdrawing from the border and now from
the crimea
well indeed today is the day x that
basically that was a
an announcement that sent diplomats
scrambling out of kiev expats leaving uh
filling flights the few rainy flights
that were operational in those past few
days even some of ukraine's richest
people doing their best to leave the
country as fast as possible and now here
we are in kharkiv 40 kilometers from the
russian border and it is pretty much
business as usual a normal working day
here um i think in terms of the kind of
dates that was always going to be a very
difficult call we know vladimir putin
doesn't like doing what's expected of
him and i think that was the american
strategy to basically spell out what
they thought he was going to do in the
hope of encouraging him not to do it
that you know if you believe that then
that has worked um as for the troop
withdrawals well i think lots of
skepticism here in ukraine there are no
international observers on the ground
seeing those russian troops because
russia when it has been carrying out
exercises has claimed those exercises
smaller than would require allowing
international observers so basically the
world's just watching satellite imagery
trying to guess what is actually
happening on the ground from russian
military analysts we've heard that some
units that are based quite close to the
border are being drawn back to their
normal bases that are still within
striking distance of ukraine the tech
and the people the manpower that's been
brought in from siberia from the far
east they're not moving anywhere so a
sense that yes this maybe was a kind of
diplomatic overture to olaf schultz
yesterday a sign of kind of friendship
for his visit in moscow but no really
wide-ranging end to this crisis
right and tell us about this this day of
unity that's been declared for today
well it's an extra holiday albeit one
where ukrainians are still expected to
work it was only dreamt up by voldemort
zolensky ukraine's president a couple of
days ago so most people haven't really
had a chance to react yes behind me um
of course you can't see it because it's
too big there's a huge huge huge
flagpole with an even bigger ukrainian
flag that has just been hoisted in the
presence of some officials school
children are being encouraged to come to
class wearing national costume um
him has
the national anthem has been sung in
various places but i don't think it
really goes anywhere near national the
national holiday that ukraine has in the
summer this is just an attempt by the
government here to try and uh take the
initiative to kind of change the agenda
and to give people a sense that they're
on top of this because obviously the
biggest fear here in ukraine is that all
this talk of invasion is going to cause
panic we've already seen the exchange
rate weakened we've seen people buying
supplies of food in case
some kind of conflict were to happen and
that is what ukraine's government now is
worried about in the short term is panic
among the population we've seen cyber
attacks coming from russia yesterday on
government ministries and on banks
so it's not as if this pressure is
somehow subsiding russia's basically
blockading ukraine's ports on the black
sea its exports through exercise in the
black sea so yes some limited signs of
de-escalation but a very nervy ukrainian
government here trying to convince its
population that it's on top of things
that it has support from its western
partners and that there is no reason to
panic in the immediate short term all
right thanks for that nick dw
correspondent nick connolly in kharkiv
so this is all about uh russia amassing
her troops along ukraine's border
outside estimates put the number of
russian troops at 130 000 including 30
000 in belarus moscow says that some of
its forces have now returned to base but
western allies are still waiting for
evidence of that withdrawal
russian fighter jets patrolled the skies
above belarus
on the ground russian marines practice
combat drills with the belarusian army
just some of the 30 000 or so russian
troops taking part in the largest
military exercise held between the two
neighbors since the collapse of the
soviet union
in russia's northern leningrad region
more footage released by the russian
ministry of defence
this time one of its tank units involved
in another military exercise
and in the south russian warships openly
train in the black sea
the country's military buildup around
ukraine has been no secret even if
getting accurate numbers has been hard
satellite images released this week have
shed more light
these jets were photographed on sunday
at an air base in crimea an area annexed
by russia in 2014
and images of military helicopters were
taken near the russian city of selotti
not far from the ukrainian border
on tuesday moscow announced it was
withdrawing some of its forces
this gives
grounds for cautious optimism
but so far
we have not seen any sign of
de-escalation on the ground
meanwhile ukraine's military is a
fraction of russia's
its active duty troops are just a
quarter of its foes
even if civilians are being trained up
to help bridge the gap
some members of nato have been providing
ukraine with military aid
but it's hard to compete with a nuclear
power
even if it says it doesn't want war
well thomas wiegold is a journalist
specializing in international defense
and security policy welcome to dw uh
let's start with the russian claims that
they're withdrawing some troops from the
border regions including an announcement
that's just reached us from the russian
defense ministry that is now withdrawing
some troops from a crimea
should we believe them
well we have to see whether satellite
images will confirm this this might
really be happening
but the point is the troops which are to
withdraw are from garrisons quite close
to ukraine so this means even
when those troops are withdrawn they
could be relocated pretty fast pretty
soon
so withdrawn doesn't necessarily mean uh
sent home
that's exactly the point well those
troops are sent home but they are not
that far away from ukraine we have seen
that troops from russia's far east have
been relocated to belarus and close to
ukraine if those troops went home a few
thousand kilometers that would make a
difference but if there are troops which
are based a few hundred kilometers from
ukraine anyway it's not really an
improvement right
mr
mr putin uh met with the german
chancellor olaf schultz yesterday and
talked about the realities on the ground
determining what happens next what do
you think the russian president meant by
that
well from the russian point of view
russia is reacting
against pressure from ukraine against
pressure from the west
and
mr putin also mentioned that russia
considers what happens in donde was a
genocide
and he was drawing an alleged analogy to
the kosovo engagement of nato in 1999.
so this means
from my point of view russia is saying
if the situation in the eastern ukraine
gets worse we reserve the right to
intervene right and i keep hearing these
these russian claims about a genocide
who does russia believe is slaughtering
whom
well there were reports on russian tv
that the majority
government in ukraine is
suppressing slaughtering
those separatists in eastern ukraine
i think as far as i've seen there were
even claims of concentration camps so
the russian
impression or the impression russia
wants to give is that there is really a
genocide going on in in eastern ukraine
and russia has a responsibility to
protect its own people i think that's
the major point we'll have to see what
comes out of it in the next days
and as part of that the russian
parliament has called on president putin
to recognize the separatist regions of
donetsk and luhansk
as independent how would that change
things
well it's in putin's hand whether he is
to sign this into law and then if this
happens then of course russia considers
to have the not only moral but also
legal right to intervene in ukraine and
this might change things just a bit more
for the worse
if one of russia's goals has been to
frustrate ukraine's attempts to join
nato then permanently basing troops at
that border at its border with ukraine
might achieve that is that feasible in
the long term
well it depends russia surely could
deploy material to the border for
a very long time
i'm not sure whether it would be
possible to deploy troops
in this region for an indefinite time
they they have to reorganize and you
only can live in tents for so long even
if russian soldiers most probably are a
bit more robust than let's say western
european soldiers in that regard but i i
would think that at some point russia
has to take a decision whether this is a
really
big amassing of troops will stay
thank you for that that's very clear uh
defense and security journalist
thomas viggold
you're welcome
let's get more from dw's chief
international editor richard walker
welcome richard so some signs of some
movement but it sounds like it's too
early to breathe a sigh of relief
yeah i think that's right phil i mean
first of all of course it's going to
take a while to ascertain whether those
troops are really are moving what
numbers of troops are moving back where
are they moving back to are they moving
back to base or are they moving to other
forward positions from which that they
also
potentially pose a threat so there's
there are those questions still to be
answered but
still
many people have been clinging on to
that moment yesterday when this
announcement came out as is the first
sort of
de-escalatory turn
that this crisis has taken in many weeks
of ratcheting up of steady escalation
but we should stress that also yesterday
some other escalatory incidents did
happen we saw in the report there this
vote in the duma in the russian
parliament
to call on the kremlin to recognize
those rebel regions in eastern ukraine
that would be a hugely disruptive move
if the russians moved ahead with that
that would throw the whole crisis into a
new level of dangerousness
plus also there was a significant cyber
attack yesterday that took place against
various ukrainian institutions now it
always takes a while to attribute who
actually initiated a cyber attack but of
course there'll be very strong
suspicions that russia is involved given
the circumstances that we're in at the
moment plus you have a very large number
of troops certainly still in the region
around ukraine so all in all this is
still very volatile the situation
now the german chancellor olaf schultz
was in moscow yesterday following his
talks in kiev the day before did he
achieve anything
well i think he'll be reasonably
satisfied with how the trip went um i
think on two levels essentially partly
just the opportunity for him to get his
message across not just in public in the
way that we saw in the press conferences
in the report just there but also in
private several hours of getting his
message across to vladimir putin and
indicating that the western alliance is
united on this situation
and then otherwise simply the pledge
from the russian side came out to keep
talking some of the more positive noises
from vladimir putin on his interest in
talking coming out from the press
conference yesterday so i think all in
all uh schultz will be reasonably
content with how things went
uh and one of mr putin's biggest demands
is that uh nato halts its expansion
eastwards especially uh regarding
ukraine which of course nato has
rejected so how do we resolve that how
do they resolve that clash of positions
yeah well this is one of the naughtiest
questions and any talks going ahead are
really going to find difficulty
resolving this and schultz voicing some
frustration almost about the situation
sort of posing the question why are the
russians sort of instigating this crisis
over a question which is really nobody
believes that ukraine is is about to
join nato at any time soon
um and there have been some questions
about whether some sort of formula could
be found to reassure the russians that
the ukrainian membership of nato is not
imminent but one journalist
posed that question to vladimir putin
asked if he would accept something like
that and he he rejected that quite
angrily sort of saying uh when would it
then join or if it's not tomorrow when
might it be so rejecting this idea quite
quite strongly and the problem of all of
this is that vladimir putin essentially
has a strong incentive out of all of
that just to keep up this kind of level
of pressure on ukraine because if he
can't get a pledge from nato that it
won't expand
then this kind of disruption this
constant harassment of ukraine is a de
facto achievement of that goal stopping
it ever being in a position where it
could join nato all right thanks for
that richard richard walker is dw's
chief international editor